[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on va parler d'un truc
qui est à la fois sexy et à la fois pas
du tout sexy le côté sexy c'est qu'on va
parler de ea sports
on va parler forcément de tout ce qui
touche aux lys porte donc je prends ça
clashe royal class 3 ya effectivement
barthelémy dans le titre parce que ça
reste quand même d un énorme jeu en lice
port y en a plein d'autres
il ya énormément de choses qui se
passent de ce côté là et le côté ça
c'est pour côté sexy et le côté pas sexy
bas c'est qu'on arrive sur des textes du
gouvernement ou l'état effectivement
vient de légiférer en tout cas avance
pour le sport et ça c'est très bien ça
s'est ressenti sur legifrance c'est hier
aujourd'hui on est le 11 mai 2010 est le
moment où je te fais la vidéo le texte
est sorti le 10 mai au journal officiel
de la république française sous le
numéro 109 qui tu veux voix et ses
textes numéro 51
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on apprend dans ce
texte parce qu'elle apprend vachement de
choses et c'est beau je fais tout bougé
et c'est super intéressant
enfin contre un décret relatif au statut
des joueurs professionnels
nos conditions d'embauché des joueurs
professionnels du sport
les conditions d'embauché qui sont fait
effectivement pas soit par des
associations qui vont organiser des
compètes soit par des entreprises et
l'idée de ce décret et ce qui est super
intéressante pour les joueurs c'est
effectivement mais il ya un côté
protecteur
je sais pas si toi tu tues un grand fan
de jeux vidéo peut-être même que tu es
un joueur qui fait partie du circuit
elle que tu es sûr sur des compètes et
que ça concerne directement
mais ce truc là il est top pourquoi
parce que ça va encadrer déjà toutes les
entreprises et toutes les associations
pour pouvoir avoir un décret pour
pouvoir organiser des compétitions de ea
sports n'importe quelle boîte qu'ils le
volent n'importe quel assauts pourra pas
faire du sport et pourra pas avoir le
décret pour rapport organiser des
compétitions en embauchant deux joueurs
pros le truc qui tu veux c'est que
aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur un
business qui est énorme avec une
croissance à deux chiffres quand même
qui est qui est supérieur à 30% des
boîtes des entreprises des secteurs
d'activité scud moi qui aujourd'hui ont
des croissances supérieures à prendre
pour cent ça court pas les rues
donc dès que tu as un truc comme ça ça
attire tout le monde il ya à boire et à
manger tu as des entreprises les assauts
qui sont hyper sérieuse et a aussi
beaucoup de clampins qui font vraiment
de la merde
et ça c'est d'une mauvais pour le
business mauvais pour la reconnaissance
de business ça le dessert complètement
et c'est super c'est surtout très très
très mauvais pour les joueurs avec des
contrats qui tiennent pas la route avec
une surexploitation
de certains joueurs ça tu peux retrouver
effectivement dans le 10 sport tu
voulais retrouver dans le sport en
prenant beaucoup de dommage donc c'est
hyper important que l'état se positionne
par rapport à ça et protège et encadre
donc je te dis ce décret il va
effectivement encadrer les associations
et entreprises pour avoir un décret pour
répondre à un certain qu'il ya des chars
pouvoir organiser des compétitions
ça va donner effectivement aussi une
date de début de saison et une date de
fin de saison alors celles qui vont être
variable ça dépend effectivement du 10
sport que tu fais ça dépend du circuit
ça dépend de pas mal de choses donc
chaque jeu chaque activité je sais pas
quel est le terme marienne chaque
activité où chaque jeu effectivement
aura ses propres dates en fonction du
circuit parce que ce sont des circuits
internationaux donc c'est pas uniquement
la france qui va décider comment ça se
passait quand ça se passe alors c'est un
texte lee qui est paru le 10 mai et qui
sera applicable qui entrera en vigueur
comme on dit réellement le 1er juillet
2010 est donc ça va surtout être en
place je dirais à partir de la rentrée à
partir de septembre 2010 est alors c'est
vraiment bien que les pouvoirs publics
s'intéressent au sport parce que je te
disais il ya des retombées économiques
qui sont dingues ça veut dire qu'il ya
une reconnaissance qui croissante qui va
de plus en plus loin de ses activités
comme étant une activité professionnelle
à part entière donc il ya un encadrement
c'est plutôt pas mal et surtout comme
beaucoup de joueurs sont des gens qui
sont assez jeunes donc pas forcément
trop informés du droit du travail
pas forcément
au courant et qu'ils vont tout à
législation et de leurs droits par
rapport à ça donc effectivement ça en
cadre énormément pour éviter les abus
et puis pour éviter un joueur d'être
exploité de se faire arnaquer donc ça
donne vraiment voilà toute une toute une
structure layette un cadre légal qui va
protéger et ça on peut dire vraiment que
c'est une super avant c'est à dire que
la france a mis beaucoup de temps à
avancer sur le esport l'ispor s'est à
nouveau ses sauces effectivement qui en
pleine évolution et puis qui subit un
boom depuis plusieurs années mais si tu
repars au début des années 2000 en corée
et quand même le pays un des pays phare
du 10 sport
l'accord est ça fait depuis les années
2000 qui a un encadrement de cette
activité par là par les pouvoirs publics
donc on peut dire que la france a mis
beaucoup de temps alors c'est pas arrivé
tout de suite dans les années 2000 au
début des années 2000 le ea sports il
parce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui donc
fatalement il faut qu'ils aient beaucoup
de monde qui s'y intéressent troquer une
réactivité pour qu'ensuite l'état
légifère mais tu prends l'exemple de la
corée ça fait très longtemps qu'à
l'encadrement et que c'est vraiment une
activité qui est qui et légiférer qui
est protégé où les joueurs ont montré
reconnaissance et un vrai statut et il
était temps que ça arrive en france
mesdames messieurs je sais pas si vous
faites du sport
si toi même tu es un joueur de ce sport
on s'intéresse directement au score en
tout cas c'est vraiment un truc qui se
développe énormément qui va fine
continuer à se développer il a cartonné
dans les années à venir
dis moi ce que t'en penses j'entends
déjà les plus vieux c'est moi dessus je
suis grisâtre je suis fait vraiment pas
old school je peux t'assurer j'entends
déjà les plus vieux les ans est nous dit
ils font pas de sport il se pratique par
sa un truc d'autistes pas du tout c'est
vraiment un truc de dingue faut avoir un
énorme niveau pour arriver en haut des
compétitions et les placer au sommet du
mois doit si tu joues si tu t'adresses
je sais tout intérêt ça ça et si oui ben
qu'elles sont et je préférais quels sont
les trucs les plus sympas les jeux les
plus sympas du sport je pense à clash
royal parce que c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui est démocratisée 1
tout le monde ya accès c'est un jeu qui
plaît énormément qui a beaucoup de
succès mais bon rire et c'est pas le
seul dans beaucoup d'autres donc dis moi
ce que t'en penses dis moi quel son quel
est le sport qui est susceptible
d'intéresser et puis qui me parle de ça
tu mets tout ça en commentaire donc je
t'en remercie d'avoir regardé la vidéo
si ça plaît si tu trouves ce texte que
coup texte cool là là alors dit gros
pouce vers le haut
je te dis à très bientôt pour prochaine
vidéo site a des envies des idées des
suggestions interne vidéo dsit pas un tu
mets tout ça en commentaire ça me fait
plaisir on discute de ça ensemble à
beaune toi à la chaîne et moi je te dis
à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]